37 ans était incarcéré du mois d'août à
octobre 2021 à la maison d'arrêt de
toulouse c'est ce petit à petit cédric
jubile arts se confie à son voisin ils
s'inquiètent notamment de la possibilité
que le corps soit découvert marco lui
propose alors une solution je lui
suggère de détourner les soupçons n'ont
pas vers l'amant de delphine mais plutôt
vers la femme de l'amant je fais ça de
mon propre chef dans l'objectif qu'ils
me donnent une information précise sur
le lieu où pourrait être enterrée
delphine après des investigations les
pistes ouvertes ne sont pas concluantes
j'ai donné aux enquêteurs des détails
que je ne pouvais pas inventé et qui
n'étaient pas connus du public je
dispose aussi d' éléments écrits de la
main de cédric qu'il m'a transmis le 12
mai dernier une confrontation entre les
deux hommes a lieu cédric jubilaire
indique notamment que certaines phrases
prononcées ont été dit sur le ton de la
rigolade ce que dément marco
marco alors marco a été choqué de
certains de ses propos et son
comportement ce qu'il a appelé sa femme
l'autre il parle beaucoup de lui son
comportement ne me plaît pas du tout sa
femme qui a disparu il appelle tout le
temps l'autre comme si elle n'avait pas
de prêts dont il se moque des copines de
delphine quand elles passent dans des
émissions à la télé même à l'égard de
ses enfants je ne sent jamais l'amour
d'un père on tient ni marc o c'est vrai
que j'aime bien raconter ce qui se
serait passé la nuit de la disparition
de delphine une nuit il me raconte le
moment où les choses se seraient passées
il est sorti de sa chambre il a surpris
sa femme en train d'envoyer des messages
à son connard c'est comme ça qu'il
parlait de l'amant bon c'est normal n'ya
pas dire voilà et c'est là qu'il a
brillé ce sont ses mots il tente d'en
savoir plus en donnant des idées à
cédric cette idée de déplacer le corps
de delphine vient de moi je fais ça de
mon propre chef comme une amie on
l'avait eu là d'un objectif qui me donne
une information précise sur le lieu où
elles pourraient être enterrés
s'inquiétait de la possibilité qu'un
corps enterrés finissent par être
découvert à cause des intempéries ou des
animaux c'est là qu'il me dit que le
corps de sa femme et en tirait pas loin
d'un endroit qui a brûlé il me parle
aussi de deux grands arbres sans donner
plus d'explications il rencontre aussi
rencontré aussi la nouvelle campagne de
série cupid à un marco
maddii me renvoie et 10 me renvoie vers
séverine celle qui considère comme sa
nouvelle femme il me dit qu'elle sait
tout mais qu'elle va me montrer aux
intérêts delphine il me demande donc de
la contacter à ma sortie de prison une
semaine ou deux avant ma libération il
me donne des lettres avec des messages
codés à lui remettre en mains propres je
me sens dans l'obligation de raconter
tout ça aux renseignements pénitentiaire
gilles alors c'est très circonstancié il
maintient toutes ses déclarations il
donne des détails c'est ça qui a appris
que depuis le début les enquêteurs ils
se sont connus trois mois d'août à
octobre 2021 en cellule ils ont commencé
à dialoguer par la fenêtre et lui marco
c'est son surnom maintien tout mais
cependant pourquoi ils s'expriment c'est
parce qu'il est quand même un tout petit
peu en difficulté et marco on l'accuse
certains disent tu à négocier ça contre
une libération anticipée d'autres
d'autres prétendent que peut-être il
aurait pu inventer parce que lors des
fouilles ans n'a rien trouvé donc pour
le moment y'a rien mais lui maintient
coûte que coûte ses déclarations voilà
et c'est vrai que la confrontation n'a
rien donné au grand dam des enquêteurs
et marco a dit lui ce qu'il voulait
c'était pas par la série cupid a
vraiment il a dit lui ce qu'il voulait
c'était pour être trompés oui je veux
avoir la paix pour dormir la nuit pour
regarder mes programmes de télé préférée
les marseillais sur w9 et les émissions
de cyril hanouna sur ces 8 c'est pas
vraiment ça j'embrasse marco voilà et
j'espère qu'il peut nous regarder
tranquillement en paix voilà marcos à
samassa m'a touché voilà donc marco nous
regarde ah oui il dit dans une interview
également qu'il le fait pour les enfants
de belfin gillard exactement il estimait
que ces enfants devaient avoir la vérité
exactement voilà donc et on ne sait
toujours rien comme ça et c'est fou
c'était cette histoire est incroyable ça
pour ça qu'elle passionne c'est qu'elle
n'avance pas on n'a toujours pas
retrouvé delphine a disparu au prince et
dans sa date du 15 décembre 2020
disparition ça fait un moment en
revanche qui précise aussi ce marco qui
est un faux nom on le rappelle un surnom
c'est un surnom j'ai regardé son oeuf
discrétion vous êtes bernard motté vous
a plu en fait luc reichmann
est en fait merci même plus ce que je
voulais dire avec ma c'est normal ça
non je voulais dire qu'en prison en
prison elle était détesté parce qu'ils
dépouillent il apparaît comme arrogant
et qui se fait insulter par tous les
autres codétenus et ça et à l'isolément
il est à l' isolement vraiment protéger
apparemment marco fournissez du cannabis
en prison à cédric jubilent à redon
qu'il était aussi rapprochés par ça et
c'est peut-être aussi chez ca qui se
confiait la nuit à passer ce qu'il
raconte il demande donc là pour y faire
franchement je préfère la nouvelle julie
lescaut elle c'est vrai forcément c'est
vrai
[Rires]
pas mal